اثر تقرير بثته قناه تلفزيونيه المانيه
شبهها رفع لاعبي المنتخب المغربي لاصبع
السبابه بما يفعله تنظيم داعش ردود فعل
غاضبه وساخره في نفس الوقت بين نشطاء
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي في الوطن العربي
والغربي حيث قارن التقرير بين صور يرفع
فيها لاعبون المنتخب المغربي
سباباتهم الى الاعلى في غرفه تبديل
الملابس وبين صور لمقاتلي داعش وهم يرفعون
السبابه
[موسيقى]
عريسون باكستاني يفاجئ وزوجته في ليله
الزفاف بهديه غريبه اذ احضر لها حمارا
صغيرا وفي فيديو على انستغرام
ظهر العريس ازلان شاه وهو يحضر الحمار الى
حفل زفاف ويقوم باهدائه لزوجته وعن سبب
اختيار العريس تلك الهديه قال زوجته تحب
الحمير وانا ايضا فالحمار حيوان محب
ومجتهد الفيديو حصد اعجاب عدد من رواد
مواقع التواصل اجتماعي وراى بعضهم ان
الهديه لطيفه وتؤكد اهميه عدم التعامل
بسلبيته مع الحيوانات
[موسيقى]
تداول ارواد مواقع التواصل اجتماعي مقطع
فيديو لنائي بالسفير الفرنسي في سلطنه
عمان نشد فيها باللغه العربيه المشجع
المنحوس مجوبه بعد ما ارتدى قميص المنتخب
الفرنسي في مباراه المغرب السفير قال
عزيزي ماجون بان الدعوك للتوقف عن تشجيع
فريقنا وان ترتدي قميصا ابيض مثل قلبك
باسم عزيزي ما زومبا هذه الرساله من طرف
نائب السفير الفرنسي لدي سلطنه عمان نعلم
انك في كل مباراه ترتدي قميص الفريق الذي
تسنده ولكن لاحظنا ايضا انه بكل مره تاتي
النتيجه بعكس ما تتمناه باسم الصداقه بين
فرنسا والمغرب وباسم الصداقه بين فرنسا
وسلطنه عمان ندعوك اليوم ان ترتدي قميصا
ابيض اللون مثل قلبك على امل ان نشاهد معا
المباراه النهائيه لكاس العالم اي كانت
النتيجه
كان هذا كل شيء لليوم الى اللقاء